chant c'est 1200 habitants un bourg
tranquille une commune de touraine posé
sur la rivière brain presque endormi
depuis 2010 cette année de fermeture de
la boulangerie locale
mais depuis quelques jours il règne
comme une effervescence à l'initiative
de la mairie et de trois associés une
épicerie vient d'ouvrir ses portes dans
l'ancienne caserne des sapeurs pompiers
et voilà que la magie du lien social
réapparaît pour le plus grand bonheur
des habitants
ça faisait longtemps que l'on n'avait
plus grand chose ici et puis bon je leur
souhaite vraiment de réussir parce que
ça vaut le coup
on sent qu'il ya du potentiel on n'avait
pas d'épicerie dans le coin vous allez
jusqu'à verbier
quand j'ai besoin d eux des trucs c'est
juste à côté c'est génial quelle bonheur
de revoir commerces du village
ah oui alors à vous manquer terriblement
ça j'espère que ça va marcher pour que
les gens s'y jouent le jeu de la
baguette à la carte de pêche en passant
par les fruits et légumes c'est le
circuit court qui est favorisé un coup
de pouce pour une économie locale
vertueuse des producteurs locaux on en
trouve dans le département mais aussi
dans le village d'à côté par exemple
pour du miel dans un autre village à 5
km pour du café ou même sur des produits
non alimentaires comme du savon
on a une personne qui fabrique des
savons à dix kilomètres d'ici un vrai
lieu de vie renaît entre panier de
courses et prochainement points de
retrait d'argent dépôt de colis service
de pressing de cordonnerie et de la
petite restauration
le 18 juin 2007 ce dernier commerce de
la commune une boulangerie a fermé et
moins de quatre ans après on a réussi à
réinstaller à nouveau commerce pour la
satisfaction de tous laventure n'a
décidément que des avantages puisque
deux emplois ont été créés et que deux
autres le seront prochainement
la commune retrouve de la vitalité